[Music]
this problem good evening everyone
welcome back with a few minutes were
resuming tonight's Thursday night's
lecture with the Grand Master and
commemorative at it back here with you
my last lecture at the st. Louis chess
club within the period I was here as the
Grand Master resident after me Grand
Master Robert honkofsky will take over
from tomorrow and you are welcome to
send your games and questions to info at
st. Louis's club at work and I'm sure it
will be very helpful and with his
extensive knowledge can help you with
your questions so tonight we are back
with games from Romantic era so I had
this discussion with being all the times
okay there aren't that much handful of
games and a lot of them have become
irrelevant over the years because of the
modern theory and a lot of other things
so so I kept thinking what could be so
interesting and so appealing and so
meaningful nowadays and that then I
think that it kind of striking it struck
me the endgame the angle rules haven't
changed our findings have changed
because of the control of the engines
but the openings have the end games
haven't changed right and and because of
mutual mistakes sometimes very
interesting any games used to occur back
at a time so comparing the engines from
old days and nowadays kind of makes
sense you can learn a lot of materials
you can find a lot of interesting
materials to compare so I first start
actually this is not what I want to show
first excuse me I want to show you this
one first
Oh
sorry man sorry so this is a game
between a yoking or alkyne the fourth
world champion the only world champion
who died as a world champion and tar
took over who is a famous chess figure
and was one of the top players by at a
time but he was a he was a client of
both other kind and and kappa blanka so
was his front player but not that strong
so for example this endgame pawn race
with the number unbalanced material it's
a very common theme happening business
you know what was that if you are
following online chess and online
tournaments and important ones there was
a critical game in Paris with an
unbalanced material the game between
Kremlin and Caruana round for I think of
the candidates in 2018 in Berlin where
car one I wanted with black pieces which
I will show you right after this one and
that was a turn of event because nothing
then Caruana was in lead with three out
of four he beat the player who was in
league with black pieces Kramnik and
then it was all upward for Caruana and
downward for for Kramnik and and I want
to show you so the pawn rise for example
here so black has two very strong
pastors with it with the support of the
bishop eyeballing to get to either g3 to
support if he wants but the problem is
that the Father pawns promotion score is
not of the same color of this bishop and
that problem black has is that the rook
is cutting off the king - the king
editor can not do anything White's King
on the other hand is far from the pawns
but he can't get closer and more
importantly what has the G passed pawn
so once you manage if once white manages
to stop black spawns right you can start
promoting the palm because the King
cannot get close enough so this is what
you move give everyone up to five
minutes the move is very the right move
it's very contradictory
because okay if I say what what what in
a sense of the movies I kind of devolved
kind of divulging the answer so I let
you think second why'd you play there RQ
wish to win this there is a clear way
and there is a less clear when that
computer shows that the engines show but
the first one makes sense for humans
brain so okay everyone five minutes do
we have any suggestions been to begin
with now I'll give everyone five minutes
I'll go suggestion already so King C to
e4 actually I can you can play King to
rook to d4 after death so king c2 is
actually black yeah this is King C to
give him second I'm just trying to
remember what's the right move for
hmm
okay king c2 I go alright f3 doesn't
work because you can go King City after
doesn't work because you can go King III
King see to e4 then before yes I mean
you can't go rock before but he's also
working well before e3 then you can go
King t3 that's that's winning huh wait a
second I'm not okay let's see
King see to e4 do I mean I cannot go
after you go King d3 well I mean before
you have the move rook t4 that's the if
I could III you you get your king where
you want to get the king to f3 and
that's game over so when you go rock t4
I have maybe to play f3 rook takes e4
have to look check but then you wind
upon
it's a kink see - oh [ __ ]
oh my god it's the pons f3 that's works
that King City works I'm sorry I'm sorry
pause oh it's black team of black
players among f3 now you cannot go
looking c2 if you looking c2 then it's
too slow
this is very funny I have taught this
position at least 15 times this is the
third time I think I make this mistake
I'm asking what's blacks to move but
when it bends blacks was watching well
I'm gonna see why the king is too close
and I
so the point is very close now right and
black is threating blacks actually plays
very threatening right comes a
forty-three comes very fast so you have
to stop the pawns right all right for
the time I wasted I kind of going to
talk about it so after the move white
placed but after after but they do move
look to the rook to d5 very strong off
now if he goes efore then who goes to
behind and then the king will march to
win the pot and black can't do anything
about it let's have a look for example
this this this and then this then I just
placed my rope King here and this to
grab this one although I'm thinking
maybe I also can play this move because
this is even closer to win at all
because after III is not still not
possible I win the pot anyways so before
is not working if I go F to which I
think that was the move in the game I
can just go back to d1 back now these
two pawns the pawns F 3 and a 3 is very
strong but now that the pant was already
detached from the 3rd rank so after E -
before I have enough time to get close
now the king controls the ponds the pond
is this pond if the picture was
LightSquared oh my god that would have
been a nightmare right the bishop is
dark squirt it's all I can do is to play
with g5 and then promote the Jeep on
these ponds and the bishops can't do
anything that the entire the idea is
that I am going to prevent a move the e4
move which is very contradictory you are
living the background let the pond gets
to sit on you go back you basically are
saying I'm going I give you a move to
play off to another score of d1 but the
entire idea is not to let the pawns join
each other so you see this position then
see the themes keep repeating themselves
up sorry sorry when I gotta find the
right position
so Wow anybody follow this game
this is Kramnik white against Caruana
this was the key game of the 2018
candidate in my opinion it's kind of
decided to tournament because after that
crime he couldn't play at all and
Fabiana just cruised through the
tournament winning it in style so
looking for was played with the idea up
there c3 I am play King g6 okay I'm not
going to talk about the details of this
most all computer analysis I just want
to talk about once the pond race gets
close to the to the end of it
King d6 rooks c6 was supposed to be
played again representing button again
there's a lot to be learned
h5 was played a seven and okay eight now
this is a critical moment
again another pond race right I'm
balanced material white has water like
has what black has an extra piece white
has four points two points for the
sacrifice piece and white spawns are
more advanced than blacks
well I cannot expect you to find most as
Kramnik mr. right can I say I've played
before but the most c4 was necessary
because after this pawn sacrifice he
could go up to see it
so when you do Paris's think about think
about what think about back ranks
because that's where you were promoting
so they played before this and that's c4
but he could go alright this is a bit of
tactic here
houki and of course doesn't work because
of our wins an exchange
and the bishop is nicely controlling
these two parts because the pawns are
not connected so White has good winning
chances anyways I don't want to go into
the details of this game and the
dramatic part of it but Paul races right
it was happening in all these two horses
happen all the time let's see in the
Romantic era how they were handling it
huh let's go put it so let's let's talk
a little about the Romantic players so I
have a stainless here I have Blackburn
question of when ever what who has heard
the body never who was he then he has
heard of me never what do you think yeah
he introduced the idea in French right
what's that
you know he's the first thing we gonna
know I think I think it's human or semen
she won't even ever that's his opening
you've seen that before
who hasn't seen it before who hasn't
seen this before everybody else is good
everybody have seen this before that's
great what's that play this is good
so yeah so we never we never his game so
let's start with the winner was game
against Anderson day and who was ad love
Anderson he was not a grandmaster you
know I ask my students that was this guy
and that guy and if they think they're
famous they would think that guy is
probably a grandma and they are right
because I'm asking about someone famous
right but this guy is not contemporary
the title of grandma didn't exist before
1914 only the title of Grand Master was
introduced after 1914 to the and it the
title was bestowed to the players who
qualify to the second round of the final
of the same st. Petersburg tournament
1914 by the Russian czar to capablanca
Lasker Jochen I think it was nimzowitsch
and tarish or he was marshal Ontario I
don't know him I don't remember exactly
I think was marshal entourage so these
are the first grandmasters ever so he
was a title bestowed like that at a time
so so understand wasn't a grandmaster
because this game is from 1800 see was
living in 1800 so who was he
I'll find Ursa
for a period maybe the best player he is
one of the founder of the romantic eras
chess attack and beauty at any cost
immortal game and evergreen those are
his two best is famous for evergreen and
immortal games okay well let's look at
his game look at this game he played
against whenever so we never didn't play
whenever is it this is not fair
we cannot be whenever I'm not playing
whenever I mean how can it happen okay
already whenever is disqualified already
he's on our blacklist
alright these six and take on c6 okay
you can see the the 1800 sentimental
romantic I mean you just goes G for
let's start with the tag the position is
closed like has a pair of a shell nice
grip in the center and Anderson says I
don't care I'm gonna go with my attack
so that is the sentiments of G 4G file
he'll it's romantic so I love I love
symmetry I think that's what he's saying
but also stopping game of g5 but
unnecessary right I mean she five does
it doesn't go anywhere if you go g5 hd5
you just opened this bishop and rook to
a weakness here right so I could just
copy should be seven I'm not planning to
talk about again a nice move c4 and in
accordance to the again the sentiment
open position the bishop now we never
goes for counter play he's ready why
play reckless I wanna show who is the
boss okay no one above 1500 wouldn't
make this movie now with this okay I
make that number just they can't find
but I'm just making it an average nobody
plays this move but again no
discrimination I'm not saying who knows
how much but I'm just saying on average
a lot of players will not play this move
Knight h2
Knight takes e4 what was that no no I'm
saying in this kind of position I was
talking about this no I'm not talking
about general United you know I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about
just this position in this position a
lot of players may play nice III they
may even Castle which is still a bad
move but not put the knight on the edge
of the board
when the position is open I mean you I
mean I play the move Knight issue for
them in Italian or in Spanish a very
common method and come on come on
maneuver but I'm talking about an open
position
losing a temple putting the knight on h2
don't do that
don't put the Knights and the edge and
that's not a rule just just for the most
part don't do that Knight takes e4 f3 a
knight goes to c5 I don't know if it's a
bad move it is a these are comments from
somebody else I just didn't want to
remove the comment so that didn't be but
okay let's try the positions let's
evaluate who has a pair of bishop why do
we care because the position is open
right is that right
the position is open who has a pair of
bishop who has a better point structure
who as productive development so you got
everything it's Christmas time huh just
just Bishop g7 and e4 and whites
position will collapse
but we never had other thoughts so okay
now Bishop g7 doesn't work because the
knight comes to f5 so probably Queen d7
Castle so maybe this would could helped
and then d5 but one thing is clear you
have to open up the game you have pair
of bishops your better development and
or maybe if or if if or is also
interesting maybe 4f take c4m Bishop g7
for example I don't need to take that
pawn right away back
so Matt is six so whenever is thinking
about going to D for maybe 23 Queen d7
okay he's going kind of slow so that
Vantage is fizzling out because this is
very time-sensitive advantage you are
ahead in development you are ahead in so
what if I start putting pieces together
and prevents all the breakthroughs then
it was no advantage so you have to act
upon your advantage so he's not trying
hard enough
and then a3 okay I don't see where did
this attack can go anyways oh and this
this is a bad move don't give up your
pictures too easily
okay so Trey add a new rule now just
stick to the two we had what are the two
take all the freebies number two don't
give away anything
so this also is giving away because this
also not only is a good Bishop but it
also covers the King so I don't know why
he did that
so Queen thanks D for making one sounds
fun huh
c6 I'm sure if I if I surrounding the
engine it would shout plus something for
white bad partner bad panel structure
for black complete domination in the
center misplaced Queen and a four I
think if I just knew where the Knight to
f5 should be much better okay III sounds
good sounds good a fair I think it's
still the same now you have to take the
last dude in the party the last week
piece to the party Anderson does that d5
actually this move deserve praise
because black is traditionally lost so
this is the only practical chance to
hold cd5 quintic c4f 64 so the the
romantic sentiment is gone now we have
an endgame well a winning endgame right
because what is upper pawn so neither
for d4 d5 is under attack I have to have
no way to defend d5 except if I take on
a floor that keeps black to pass pawns
and I place c4 so white has three
pastors and black has two pastors and
now we have some themes we just have to
look at right all right
we're just looking in the previous two
games we looked at the ocean kappa
blanka I'm sorry touch the cover I've
looked at we looked at cranek against
the Caruana right so this thing doesn't
have it it's ageless we always see it so
you can learn it doesn't matter which
you can so h5 trying to distract I have
decoy de-spawn but why doesn't it take
to pay attention to this what's the
easiest way to win for white what's the
easiest menu
we're talking about the last guy joining
the party who was last guy tonight other
how can he join the party night weren't
where does it go
or does it had to indeed
this may may not work but I'd like to
improve my pieces look g8 okay 94 okay
mine I got there will a las upon nice
three versus three it's getting it's
getting interesting right
d6 alright push all of these are losing
doesn't matter except the eight now who
has better pawns why that's more
advanced pawns but if black starts
rolling it comes f-5e for f3 they kind
of keep supporting they can go very fast
and white has denied which is not
helping because we say nice and also
agile remember
so if white wants to do something it
gotta be now all right now give everyone
five minutes this is a very nice
training position five minutes and this
time I didn't make a mistake it's it's
definitely watching
any questions or comments man
think of it this way you have only one
shot
you should call this series
sure I would like to hear 95 well
suppose I go f5
I keep pushing my pawns that I don't
want just one move I need a series of
move or f3 I can give up an exchange and
keep on playing or their five mainly
yes 95 was the first move comes in mind
but then I have five then I stop pushing
my part remember in the previous two
games if I showed you there was an there
was an imbalance for the minor pieces
for the for the pieces basically for non
pounds or I don't know how to say that
how would you refer because the pawn is
also a piece right or is not a piece
novice it's not a piece right okay yeah
well I'm not moving the rook that's the
thing I let you take it I play a five
I'm just sitting tight I will block it
on d7 later on ninety eight but my pawns
can gets very advanced far down the
board Knight c-5a 597 King G seven then
it comes afford f3 and they've got
things to deal with
it is a plausible choice also but c5 f 5
C 6 I take the knight you can't take my
roof I'll be happy to take one of your
passes are gone and I'm happy to to live
with that because I have three passes
now it's not the quality of the piece
isn't is the quality of your passage
that if that decides this game
it looks like Sabina is in the chat hey
honey
what does she say she says rook d5 or no
wait Roka be three first then route d5
close now it's not actually she's
missing a check on g1 she's missing
again sorry let me the move f3 because
sorry what was that sorry now no no you
don't have any to go crazy
look just let me give you some hints
black wants to the two things f5 and f3
because this also opens up this line you
gotta pay attention to both alright
it is a good choice is one of the
passive I think it's maybe the move he
played actually what's his name Anderson
and it it is still within the reality of
good winning chance but it's not game
over why it's good it's good again we're
talking about the quality of the pawns
not the quality of peace if you wouldn't
exchange by the time you get there these
parts start running so if Knight c5 f5
what happens then
two more minutes
been anything else you have - it's a
race
don't it's a race it's we accepted that
you see the first two examples was that
it's a race let's see if I was fine I go
f5 now what one thing you're forgetting
is that what does that van spawn do for
you in a lot of cases gives you the
chance to checkmate so you can go here
not 97 Rock p3 p4 or f3 doesn't matter I
have three that I take this guy and then
take on a three back now it's good to be
an open exchange sorry let me one of the
pawns if I go for the ninth x86 that's a
mate on b8 and actually it's a very nice
mate because I can add this pawn to and
you're welcome to have some coins here
as long as a checkmate there huh yeah
this night this is a very nice idea
that's mitten there
I mean Bishop c7 just April 1867 and you
you have to give up a whole drug to
prevent checkmate but then I with
wallrock extra I can stuff three parts
don't work okay are we good questions
about that good no yes
any comments people liked it okay
all right so nothing wrong with that but
now now we have a race so king takes
rook t5 so it could kind of transpose it
to what you said Bishop f6 rook c5 f3
Rock c7 check actually now things are
getting a little complicated that King
e6 d7 Bishop d8 but I think after this
check f2 black is doing really really
well what should be very very careful
not to this disposition one mistake
Knight xt7 and let's go over the win
maybe there was some subtle win
somewhere but the main point is that it
wasn't about how much material you have
because once there's a pawn race there's
a pond race so I don't know
doesn't look doesn't look so so decisive
to me I can't see ok I'll ask you this
is winning but still then here some
accuracy is required so he played he
didn't play a check he played Bishop t8
Torx t6 check King e7 rook c5
now what shall we do rocky for I don't
know what was this f2 we never played
giving up the pawn with check so he had
to play rocky for but these are still
very interesting Bishop b6 I think this
should be a drop probably this is
probably a job
but look if one doesn't make sense also
you can make them we can make some other
moves with your rook but you see how
getting district on c5 it stops the c4
pawn white white one in exchange but his
pawns got paralyzed they cannot go
further any any any any score further so
there's a blunder rook 65 their rookie
to check 54 doesn't matter now now he's
winning now it's easy right nice game
over never say it's easy Runa okay rule
number three this is lateral never say
it's easy never say it's easy now King
c2 Bishop g7 Rock t2 check King b1 I
don't know why he did that he can't
equal go King D one right
okay now his preparing them of rook c5
okay everything's going according to the
plan for Anderson okay this is winning
right what's the best way to win
yep but is real techy five wins or not
rook 8 XE five
why you can't stop the pie camp lurking
situ
yeah that's the easiest way to win and
then taken if I what about taking now
does it win
you know because he's gonna be able to
maneuver the King to be just in time to
protect the promotion yeah but you can
promote any time you have two pawns
let's have a look well you are right but
that's then that's that's the tragedy
for for Anderson here he played this
mistake and then it was a draw yeah but
I don't have to do that I can't play b5
if f3 I can go King did you if King f3
didn't over here then here after this
well I have this pawn extra right so I
can go here and then I promise a / I
give up - what's that what what's that
without the upon the dryers without the
upon because is the King far yes the
King is far yeah
no the the one for the okay let me show
you these guys now the the area is from
here to here here and here
this is cores out you can't work with
the King here so anything within
including the squares are covered this
area is winning anything outside of it
so the king is just outside of it if the
chemos on d2 is yeah this is the winning
area this the king is close enough to
win it will be obvious because yeah you
can I get close enough you won't try
yeah you want to try with the King on e5
maybe that's the hardest one and you
everybody wants to learn that one won't
do it okay let's do it
okay let's let's get the Queen claw so
give a check so I don't want to put my
king in front of the pawn right that
that helps the King to get closer
so King each one queen is seven check
King there
Queenie for check right I'm just waiting
check
okay maybe if I was also excluded maybe
if I was also not this square yeah if I
was also not a square I think so maybe
it was we did today the border schools
that do not count either but I pretty
much remember that's the that's the
thing because all right I give a check
and goes here check here here King here
well maybe I can pin for further here
but then the king can go here because
you know if the King goes here I think I
can plug this one oh yeah so can I get
that position or no
so because the King on this one doesn't
with the King on his phone doesn't work
can I get that position kind of force
that so I had to force the King on g1
yeah but it's a nice versus Queen at
night search which moment I mean with
this with what switch position I'm
talking if Kim Ji Won but then I go King
Queen e2 and you have to go back and the
my king is close enough that's it no no
no that's well the thing is that I
always go I can always go King edge to
ah but then okay but if I don't go to
Jeju we get a position our detail I mean
right
all right right right right right that's
the easy bit
I mean Queen d2 was also working right
because I still get the position
yeah which one all right right right
right so a queen of fun so you'll give a
check then right you have to go here
then a wait a second
so if here the King goes here and then
what I have to do well then I can't
looking g1 maybe if I was also excluded
maybe maybe it was this maybe it was
lower I think was lower probably this
was discourse so I think this was the
score I think this is score is also not
close enough with King III okay all
right so before I move to the different
and game the most recent example was
played around five of the grain K
International the one with Carlsen
Caruana
Island and all the top lid of the bottom
bottom team in cultural Germany played a
day ago game between game between
Grandmaster
well not Grandmaster now he's a student
a national master but the German prodigy
I mentioned is that Vincent climber and
George Meier
so in this position the position
there's another pond race so he played
this I think this may be our way to
behind me here
this is a game between khaimah Vincent
hi mother the the German child prodigy
is 49 is like 2,500 fidei and he won the
grand key open last year so he qualify
for the closed tournament the classic
this year against George Mayer
so this okay takes takes
and now here again another Paris White
was ahead but now we have two passers
right now the Jewish mob wisdom of c4
why because after B takes c4 you can
play g2 now in the actual game black
played g2 first and then lost the quimby
a check very strong move because if I go
King gets fun now
Quidditch a check sorry not check winch
8 and if I Queen then check I trade the
Queens and then I win the pot I promote
but here black miss the most c4 and
after take them G - because if I play
cool couldn't be a check King each one
and queen is either have g1 Queen check
which Dan is now losing everybody makes
sense to everyone so let's have a look
at this game which was played so
Anderson whenever was 1878 we are 2019
the same thing same work repetitive
right and games never get old
alright now let's look at another one
this is another one so I am NOT going
since we don't have so much time I'm not
going to go over the entire game I was
planning to
so this is a game from the match between
Stennis and Blackburn as you can see the
result over here he wants seven to one
that's very convincing right but the
games weren't that hard to say in favor
of Staines so in fact there were so many
blunders so for example in this game he
missed him of 9h fire for example which
is which wins on a spot and then f6g six
wins because XG six is not possible 96 i
taked it night and I'm winning all right
I just take take it back sorry and it's
just paint so anyways the game continued
I'm not going to talk much about this so
they traded game got simplified a lot of
a lot of stuff happening which I wanted
to cover but we don't have that much
time so I want to get to the endgame
right away
all right first question in this endgame
so who is better
that's the question number one
the lightness expended in mm-hmm
what about if after I played this my
rookie 5 and then d5
now like his favorite right so white had
missed your point is exactly right
white messed up somewhere shouldn't he
have played this move I think I think
you should have taken only five earlier
and then take 95 here because now D
takes d5 then he can go just h4 and then
94 94 right away so the point is after
rook e5 f takes e5 then he can go 90 494
h6 and h4 that of course touch one the
position is balanced but I think white
is a little bit have upper hand so b3 h5
rookie 5d 594 King g7 Knight c3 now
black starts to improve his position c6
that's a good trade right trading toward
the center in the endgame is good
because central pass pawns are not that
dangerous are they
it has the center is the closest place
forever all the pieces to get there
right so it's easier to control right so
in the opening is hard because there are
so many pieces playing toward the center
but in the end game is the best place to
have to control your opponent passers I
really like to smoke for 55 actually I
like it yeah well because of a tactics
not because Bishop d5 doesn't work
because of 97 and there's a check on d2
and the knight can also go to d4 and
after this now I really like what what
Blackburn did 9741 a knight c8 very
strong of the knife citizen d6 make a
blockade and that we should money for is
really really really useless
look see 196 because it comes with a
thread even other of this check King
just King FA the bishops hanging and
white should have played King III and
the black just can play rook c8 trade
the rocks or okay rook d7 but I can take
take Roxy to activity it makes draw very
possible why the way after this T six
that just remember don't start grabbing
pawns what's wrong with Luke g2 it's
losing these pawns now play the role of
a shelter for whites King what goes King
defies King e6 then the pond will be
promoted the local games are about the
quality of your pastor your pass funds
your work and your King not about how
many pounds we have same thing with the
pawn rush to the pond with the with the
pawn race right
I didn't magnetic White was an open
exchange remember in the understands
game or the other ones it's about how
well your pawns are advanced so after
this fruity to very strong move the game
is a draw white cannot what can take
that pawn may seven but then black picks
up the pawn on d6 it's gonna be here
sure
so he played Bishop d3 and here we have
you for it's getting it's getting
complex done Bishop c4 takes takes b3
check King you to not it's not before
check is kind of annoying it's time for
it's time for Stannis to think about
bailing out one thing about romantic
error is that you never bail out you
play all the way to live till the end
for a win no matter what the position
evaluation is that's very romantic
okay 7 I don't know if this changes
devaluation but definitely not unless
you work with Europe 94 check and King
III finally made a mistake very strong
of King g8
well II to is not possible right because
of this check rook takes 8 and thanking
me to takes the pony to make sense
so King g8 he plays rook e7 still some
kind of threat
so as the last last two questions why to
play sorry black to play
last one is what you play
last one is also black to play sir so I
think we gotta pick up this joke right
and after d6
we pick up the freebies and be stingy
how can you be stingy here
there's only one move no it's it's black
to move
no gifts Oh
there are all the tools if I got these
seven you just cannot see six right and
then the King comes over and your upper
I have to take the brook you take my
bishop and you wrap a piece on winning
right so now King takes d4 my working if
it oops or now I cannot take bishop
takes f7 because of it too and if I pick
up this pond and there's roughly seven
so Luke's game over right let's make it
complicated King g5
kingi eight so far so good I'm getting
my king closer King c6 and King d8 I
mean we could also pretty sake it so far
so good the rookies the rook is
untouchable you can't touch it
King b6 f5 okay
now that the racial starts right I
cannot just stay there
why it starts that with the a pond I
have to do something with my pawns right
f5 a for f4 oh he played oak f6 the
movies okay look in a king DS 7 or a for
both are winning knocking this away
because I make the King goes to c5 and
then okay 5 check another tempo and
wherever the king goes I pick up one of
the pots so he went so he went rook of 6
king c6 now what what do you think is
the valuation of the position last
question who is winning
how
all right let's have a look then here is
the mistake actually here the last
chance for black was Rookie six with the
IDE - and a sufficiently - okie five I
stopped the pawns now I activate my
pieces before
looking for activity so when when your
pawns are stopped the only way is peace
activity and that means a lot of
activity not just one or two black could
hold black could hold with rookie six
not it's a draw this this and that will
be looking for a five to six okay for
black his last yes King b6 okay to a
seven Kingdom now this is not how the
game went this takes takes and they was
promote at the same time that's gonna be
draw so and so I talked about rules and
there's one axiom about chess just as
hard
that's what axiom so in the game you
played the move f4 now we go a 5 you can
see 8 is 6 & b8 and
what's that what's fine yeah no it just
happened to be here but to just push I
said it's a race right remember just I
asked so ok faith but this this pawns
are just honest I think I think he just
had to play here King b6 actually an a7
and Bishop e5 mates but anyways white
one the pond'rous because black did two
things wrong he was too passive and when
it mattered he didn't try to activate it
well when it mattered he didn't push the
pawns what was White's mistake the over
poop were pressed ended up having a lost
position
so being objective in the in the endgame
is very important very important only if
it could be and game is the is the
nicest part in my opinion to study in
all era because the rules and the depth
is all the same because it has its own
logic and it has its own rules it never
changes so if one thing we have in
common with 200 years ago in chess is
the endgame I hope you guys had fun
thank you guys
have a good evening Thanks
you
[Music]
you